et avec nous pour ce club Benjamin Morel
bonjour Benjamin merci d'être avec nous
Frédéric d'habits bonjour Frédéric
exception générale opinion de l'institut
de sondage il faut qu'on va parler de
votre sondage
on va parler de la réforme des retraites
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation à
l'appel des syndicats prévus demain
alors quel objectif alors que le
président semble ne pas reculer sur ce
texte et puis on parle de votre sondage
Frédéric les intentions de vote en cas
de législatives le grand gagnant le RN
le grand perdant la majorité
présidentielle de quoi peut être
refroidir le président procéder à une
dissolution Frédéric nous analyserait
ses résultats avec Benjamin d'abord on
va voir l'actualité dans nos régions on
parle des violences de ce weekend à
Sainte Soline
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Poitiers retrouver Baptiste bise
bonjour Baptiste merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur adjoints de la
Nouvelle République et Centre Presse
dans la Vienne et évidemment Baptiste
vous avez suivi de près les événements
de sainte Soline puisque c'est votre
journal qui couvre cette zone alors
après un week-end de violence le calme
est-il revenu
alors oui on peut dire que le calme est
revenu ce matin dans le Poitou après le
rassemblement de samedi qui a été marqué
par des affrontements d'une extrême
violence entre les forces de l'ordre et
les militants antibacine à Sainte-Soline
hier dimanche après la bataille des
chiffres après la bataille sur le
terrain c'était l'heure de la bataille
des chiffres et au billets un terrible
décompte des victimes le procureur de la
République de Niort a fait état de deux
urgences absolues et de 27 urgences
relatives dans les rangs légendaires
essentiellement pour des brûlures dit-il
des traumatismes liés à des jeux de
projectiles des traumatismes sonores
pour que chacun puisse mesurer aussi la
violence de l'assaut portée par les
manifestants la gendarmerie a rendu
public une vidéo filmée depuis
l'intérieur d'un véhicule on peut
effectivement y voir une pluie de
projectiles de pierre de Cocteau
numéroto cocktail Molotov pardon
s'abattre sur les gendarmes qui
protégeaient le chantier de construction
de la réserve d'eau de sainte Soline du
côté des manifestants le procureur de
Niort retient trois urgences absolues
une femme de 19 ans victime d'un
traumatisme facial un homme de 27 ans
blessé au pied puis surtout un homme de
30 ans hospitalisé au CHU de Poitiers
pour un traumatisme crânien et pronostic
vital était toujours engagé hier soir de
leur côté les organisateurs de cette
manifestation qui avaient été interdite
ont également fait le point hier eux des
nombres 200 blessés dans leur rang dont
40 blessés graves ils accusent également
les autorités d'avoir ralenti l'arrivée
des secours sur place des observateurs
de la Ligue des droits de l'homme ont
aussi constaté des entraves au secours
alors à Paris le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'est défendu hier il a estimé que ce
sont les manifestants les plus radicaux
qui ont empêché les opérations de
secours de se dérouler normalement
la contestation a pris un nouveau visage
est-ce qu'on assiste à des violences
inhabituelles
ouais on peut dire que le rapport de
force entre les opposants au bassines et
les autorités à atteint un niveau de
violence inédit ce week-end dans les
Deux Sèvres les cinq journalistes de
notre journal La Nouvelle République qui
était sur Terre le terrain ils peuvent
en témoigner c'était encore plus violent
que lors de la grande manifestation
d'octobre dernier ici cette guerre de
l'eau n'est pas nouvelle les lecteurs de
La Nouvelle République qui connaissent
le dossier par cœur il suivent le débat
depuis plusieurs années alors pour
rappel en Poitou nous avons la
particularité de ne pas avoir de relief
pour construire des retenues colinaires
nous avons aussi la particularité
d'avoir des nappes phréatiques de toutes
petites tailles qui se vident chaque été
qui se remplissent en principe chaque
univers enfin en tout cas les hivers où
il pleut c'était pas le cas l'hiver
dernier l'idée de ces réserves de
substitution que l'on appelle bassine
était de Pompée dans les nappes univers
pour stocker de l'eau en surface et
l'utiliser pour l'irrigation l'été et
pomper moins dans les cours d'eau dans
les Deux-Sèvres un protocole d'accord
prévoyant en contrepartie le
développement de pratiques
agroécologiques a été signée en 2018
voyez que c'était pas tout frais c'est
pas c'était quand même il y a 5 ans 16
bassines sont en projet dans la Vienne
un protocole d'accord a été signé plus
récemment c'était en octobre livre
dernier il prévoit la construction de 30
bassines les autorités préviennent que
ce n'est qu'un début elles veulent
multiplier ses projets au nom de la
souveraineté alimentaire du pays alors
c'est sans doute pourquoi les opposants
qui dénoncent la main mise des irrigants
sur la ressource en eau s'attaque au
premier chantier de construction de
sébacine celle de en construction dans
les Deux-Sèvres d'autant que cette
ressource en eau est de plus en plus
rare avec les effets du changement
climatique la cible de la bassine de
sainte Soline n'avait donc pas été
choisi au hasard c'est vrai qu'un défilé
pacifique dans les rues de Niort ou de
Poitiers n'auraient pas provoqué de
telles affrontements mais ça n'aurait
pas non plus placé le débat sur la scène
médiatique nationale Amel dans le sud
des Deux-Sèvres plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont participé à des débats sur
la question de l'eau et les animations
festives tout le week-end et le
rassemblement était totalement éclipsé
par les scènes de guérilla de sainte
Soline merci beaucoup Baptiste d'avoir
été avec nous on regarde la ligne de la
nouvelle république bassine un bilan
humain très lourd c'est à la Une de
votre journal aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Baptiste bise pour faire suite aux
propos de Baptiste est-ce que ça donne
raison à ceux qui disent que pour se
faire entendre et bien il faut en passer
par la violence c'est l'un des dangers
c'est à dire que si vous prenez les
mouvements qui ont conduit à un échec de
l'exécutif ces dernières années vous
n'avez pas 36 vous avez Notre Dame des
Landes où là vous avez eu un référendum
mais où la violence entre guillemets à
triompher les gilets jaunes alors pas
évidemment tout mouvement des gilets
jaunes mais souvenez-vous de la journée
du 8 c'est essentiellement les
dégradations de l'Arc de Triomphe etc et
à ce moment là où le pouvoir donne le
sentiment de céder il y a un an les
manifestations en l'honneur d'Yvan
Colonna ou là également vous avez
ensuite un embrayage et une grosse modo
à l'état récapitule donc aujourd'hui on
voit que malgré tout cette violence là
et bien elle va être vue par une partie
de la population comme étant payante et
ça c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que
si d'un côté vous avez des mouvements
sociaux qui sont qui apparaissent comme
étant pas relativement vain parce que
nous menons jamais à une négociation
réelle et de l'autre côté une violence
qui paie on peut rentrer dans une
logique qui est une logique dangereuse
oui je partage qui vient d'être dit
c'est vrai que l'État sur un mouvement
social classique un gouvernement n'a pas
recueillé depuis le CPE depuis 2006 ça
fait longtemps et c'est vrai que sur
cette idée que la violence permet de
faire avancer les choses c'est
particulièrement et de plus en plus
partagé par la jeunesse qu'est-ce qu'on
a vu ces derniers temps du côté des
jeunes du côté des primes mauvais temps
ils n'ont pas voté à l'élection
présidentielle en 37% d'absence ça ne
s'était jamais vu pour est-ce que ta
présidentielle ou autre normale les
jeunes peuvent voter autant voir plus
que l'ensemble des Français et l'idée
que puisque le politique n'arrive plus à
changer les choses puisqu'il n'arrive
plus à changer la vie puisqu'il n'arrive
plus à faire avancer la situation sur la
question du climat sur la question des
inégalités femmes ou des discriminations
des deux grands sujets qui mobilisent la
jeunesse et Ben qui mieux que moi peut
faire avancer la cause y compris et
peut-être avec de la violence dans
l'enquête nouvelle vague 2021 donc les
enquêtes historiques de l'Ifop fait en
son temps par Françoise Giroud et par
L'Express on voit qu'on a entre un quart
et un tiers des jeunes qui considèrent
que et parfois nécessaire pour faire
avancer une cause
on en arrive à la réforme de retraite il
y a une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
qui aura lieu demain on a vu que les 8
premières à l'appel des syndicats se
sont bien passés que la neuvième la
semaine dernière et bien il y a eu des
violences en marge des cortèges
syndicaux est-ce que ça veut dire si on
suit cette logique que bien la violence
va s'aggraver dans les prochains jours
c'est une possibilité alors la violence
elle est quand même le fait d'individus
relativement limité et donc là il y en a
quelques-uns visiblement à Sainte Soline
est-ce qu'il rentreront à Paris on voit
qu'il y a quand même un effet peut-être
de vasque communiquante entre les deux
lieux si jamais c'est le cas il y aura
des violences mais je dirais que les
violences sont évidemment un symptôme
problématique mais c'est pas le
principal problème le problème c'est
l'acceptation et la légitimation la
violence quand vous avez comme la bien
dit Frédéric et bien une opinion qui
finit par considérer que c'est pas grave
et que peut-être même c'est nécessaire
là il y a un vrai danger si vous avez de
la violence qui est uneaniement
condamnée elle est jugulable si tout
d'un coup elle fait tache d'huile elle
est beaucoup plus problématique et le
risque en effet c'est que ben on est des
violences qui s'installe sur le long
terme dans le mouvement social qui est
un mouvement social qui est peut-être là
pour durer parce que quand même Emmanuel
Macron déciderait de suspendre enfin de
ne pas suspendre la réforme et de
continuer en pensant qu'on va changer
d'agenda il y a un risque que ça ne se
passe pas parce que les syndicats sont
mobilisés et que le référendum
initiative partagée va faire qu'ils vont
probablement aller à la collecte des
signatures donc on en a pour un
feuilleton de 9 mois si le si le
feuilleton continue que vous avez des
manifestations avec des violences et que
cette violence est de plus en plus
acceptée on rentre dans quelque chose
qui peut encore une fois être dangereux
ça veut dire que ces violences elles ne
vont pas retourner l'opinion est-ce que
la perception de l'opinion vis-à-vis de
ces violences elle a changé dans le
temps c'est clair que si la journée de
demain mardi est encore sur le mode de
celle de la semaine dernière oui il peut
y avoir il pourrait y avoir sur prudent
une logique d'opinion qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs Benjamin Morel en parlait
juste après l'Arc de Triomphe
c'est-à-dire une part des Français ce
qu'on appelle la majorité silencieuse
une France plutôt âgée plutôt rurale
sympathisants de droite qui ne vont pas
supporter cette forme de de Chanly qui
vont être inquiets qui va se déclarer
inquiète de d'une France embrasée et qui
va qui pourrait voir en Emmanuel Macron
le recours face à la violence c'est ce
qui s'était passé au moment des gilets
jaunes où on a vu entre l'Arc de
Triomphe et les élections européennes la
cote de popularité ce n'est qu'un
indicateur parmi d'autres du président
Macron remonté d'une quinzaine de points
pour l'instant Oriane parle-nous
franchement cette logique d'opinion
n'existe absolument pas mais c'est vrai
que c'est assez inquiétant de voir des
des perceptions très contradictoires
enquête il faut pour parier première la
semaine dernière deux tiers des Français
un petit peu moins 62% je crois mais 72%
des salariés souhaitent que le mouvement
se durcisse pour faire reculer le
gouvernement un sympathisant de droite
sur deux et d'un autre côté en même
temps parce que c'était la même enquête
faites après le rejet de la motion de
censure 79% des Français 8 Français sur
10 qui
[Musique]
on est super content que vous veniez
discuter du travail nous on dit ok on va
on veut venir discuter du travail mais
on veut aussi discuter des retraites on
nous dit même non mais vous pouvez pas
venir va le voir le président de la
République si vous discutez des
retraites mais vous imaginez pas quand
même qu'il y a plus de il y a 2 millions
de personnes dans la rue jeudi dernier
et qu'on va pas discuter des retraites
si on est invité à discuter à l'Élysée
du gouvernement très fort sur la
question des retraites c'est à dire
qu'il faut qu'ils disent les 64 ans ne
s'appliqueront pas et on rediscute des
retraites et du travail voilà des
discussions qui s'annoncent tendues
entre le gouvernement et les syndicats
en tout cas la première ministre elle
n'est pas prête à parler spécifiquement
de l'âge de départ elle veut lancer
d'autres chantiers sur l'emploi
l'industrie l'école la santé et
l'écologie
des priorités qui seront évoquées dans
une série de discussions d'entretiens
chorales à ce que la première ministre
durant ces trois semaines va avoir un
agenda chargé envahi jeter un petit coup
d'oeil alors aujourd'hui elle reçoit les
présidents de commission de l'Assemblée
nationale et président de la majorité
alors les commissions à l'assemblée se
sont les instances ou les députés
travaillent sur les sujets de fonds par
exemple les affaires économiques le
développement durables la culture et
l'éducation donc ça peut être
intéressant pour le gouvernement pour
dresser des feuilles de route demain
Elisabeth borne reçoit les présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat il y a
LeBron Pivet et jarre à Larcher mercredi
c'est au tour des chefs de partie de la
majorité d'échanger avec la chef du
gouvernement la semaine prochaine elle
s'entretient drap avec tous les groupes
politiques du Parlement et tous les
partis politiques y compris ce
d'opposition sans but c'est de
construire des majorités nouvelles sur
certains sujets et puis à partir de la
semaine du 10 avril elle entamera des
discussions avec les syndicats et le
patronats sur la qualité de vie au
travail l'emploi des seniors avec la
volonté de favoriser les accords entre
des partenaires sociaux un changement de
méthode et donc esquisser y compris au
Parlement après le 49-3 utilisé sur la
réforme des retraites 1/49-3 qui a été
très contesté mais elle défend quand
même son bilan dans sa méthode
parlementaire elle le rappelle depuis le
début de la législature 11 projets de
loi ont été définitivement adoptées 12
propositions de loi et il y a eu un
recours au 49-3 sur trois textes
uniquement les deux budgets et la
réforme des retraites elle fixe un
objectif pour l'avenir pas de 49-3 en
dehors des textes financiers merci Alex
Frédéric est-ce que cette méthode
d'apaisement des abattement et de nature
à calmer l'opinion quand j'entends cet
agenda déroulé par Alexandre elle parle
moins aux Français aux Français quelle
organise un cadre parlementaire
législatif elle parle au corps
intermédiaire c'est très bien mais si je
puis dire la colère je sais pas si le
terme est pertinent mais l'irritations
des Français se rejet violent de la
réforme des retraites qui n'a pas bougé
qui reste absolument massif l'autre
sujet qui est pour qui est aujourd'hui
avec cet effet de loupe politique
médiatique sous la réforme des retraites
et une sorte d'impensée l'inflation là
aux effets un G j'avais noté que le
président n'avait pas prononcé le mot
inflation il a parlé des salaires
pendant son intervention présidentielle
tout ça je pense n'est pas de nature à
faire bouger le plus en public
maintenant on est dans une sorte d'entre
nous puisque on le gouvernement et tout
le monde attend la décision et les
attendus du Conseil constitutionnel pour
éventuellement
promulguer la loi ou peut-être si cette
loi est
censurée
revenir à ce qu'elle a une nouvelle
discussion serait réformes des retraites
en tout cas c'est intéressant d'entendre
la première mise parlait d'apaisement
puisqu'il alors que on sait des mots
qu'on entendait pas elle était sur une
logique qui est transformée réformant le
pays effectivement du côté de l'exécutif
et de l'opposition on parle beaucoup de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
qui va être rendu dans le mois c'est ça
Benjamin
sortie de crise alors ça peut être une
sortie de crise mais ce serait une
sortie de crise qui évidemment ne serait
pas forcément très favorable à
l'exécutif grosso modo si jamais le
Conseil veut censurer et il y a matière
objectivement du point de vue de la
procédure vous avez quand même le 47
tirer c'est très discutable le refabus
avait fait des offres de presse au
niveau on avait parlé à l'époque pour
dire je veux au moins un vote en
première lecture sur cette loi il l'a
pas eu et vous avez tout un tas de
discussions quel texte est passé du de
l'Assemblée au Sénat c'était
intègrepopiné etc donc il y a plein
d'éléments de procédure qui peuvent
conduire à la censure globale du texte
parce que si ça c'est dur alors je dis
pas ça je vous dis c'est possible c'est
ça sinon l'autre solution c'est une
censure partielle et là en effet il y a
assez de cavaliers sociaux dans ce texte
pour que le Conseil conditionnel se
fasse plaisir il faut bien comprendre
qu'il y a 15 jours si vous m'aviez posé
la question je vous aurais dit que
politiquement pour le Conseil
constitutionnel il aurait été
extrêmement compliqué de durée
globalement ce texte aurait été lancé
une bombe nucléaire au-dessus du Palais
de l'Elysée donc évidemment
politiquement c'est compliqué là est-ce
que en effet tout le monde n'y a pas
intérêt parce que il faut voir que il y
a deux possibilités soit le monde rêvé
d'Elizabeth borne et d'Emmanuel Macron
ce qui justifie ce discours grosso modo
les choses vont se tasser et tout d'un
coup Laurent Berger va trouver tout à
fait normal d'aller négocier sur le
travail en pleine crise sur les
retraites alors qu'il est débordé par sa
base et qui a un million 400 000
personnes dans la rue possible peu
probable l'autre option c'est et bien on
va continuer à parler retraites pendant
au moins un an ou en tout cas pendant 9
mois parce que référendum d'initiative
partagé parce que syndicats qui vont
continuer à se mobiliser et l'agenda
parlementaire va être pollué parce que
de toute façon aujourd'hui il y a plus
de majorité au Parlement c'est une
solution qui induit une absence de
gouvernement quand Emmanuel Macron dit à
quelques jours écoutez on va arrêter
légiférer parce qu'on légifère trop
qu'il renonce en réalité à avoir un
programme législatif pourquoi pas mais
c'est tout de même assez lourd soit vous
avez une censure du institutionnel qui
permet au moins de passer à autre chose
c'est évidemment extrêmement compliqué
par Emmanuel Macron ce serait un
camouflet profond mais ça évite de
retirer directement une réforme parce
que on fait souvent le parallèle avec le
CPE mais il faut voir que le CPE c'était
pas 4 ans avant une présidentielle
c'était un an avant une présidentielle
et à l'époque pour Jacques Chirac c'est
renoncer à continuer réellement à
gouverner et donner qui tue à Nicolas
Sarkozy pour prendre la succession alors
que jusqu'à présent il pariait sur la
carte Villepin donc c'est réellement la
fin du shirakisme Frédéric pour
l'exécutif mieux vaut une censure qu'un
retrait c'est une manière de sortir par
l'eau mais c'est vrai je partage que
vient de dire Benjamin une censure
partielle ou surtout fait total c'est un
acte très fort et c'est pas la fin du
quinquennat mais c'est la fin de
l'ambition réformatrice du quinquennat
et vous avez raison de rappeler cette
temporalité quand je vois le discours
des Français la personnalisation du
conflit avec Emmanuel Macron c'est lui
contre nous nous disent les Français
dans une la partie de nos enquêtes
qualitatives on a l'impression que il y
a une logique de fin de règne une une
période 2006 2007 ou l'année des adieux
comme l'avait dit de leur Adler pour
François Mitterrand 1994 on en est pas
là le quinquennat n'en est même pas qu'à
son car son 20e puisque il reste quatre
ans et presque un mois
jusqu'à la fin et jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle donc tout cela serait un
coup effectivement alors nucléaire je ne
sais pas mais terrible pour l'exécutif
et surtout une façon de fracturer la
majorité donner des ailes aux
oppositions dans leur dans leur
compétition de plus en plus vives et
puis faire que les Français tourneraient
la page de l'air Macron 4 ans avant je
le répète les échéances de 2027 Benjamin
peut-être un petit un petit mot de
pédagogie pour qu'on comprenne bien
qu'est-ce qui se passe en cas de censure
alors ça dépend quel type de censure on
a ce qu'on appelle les censures totales
les censures partielles si c'est une
sensation totale ce qui est notamment le
cas pour une une vis de procédure si
jamais la procédure a Manet était
utilisée souvenez-vous en 2014 c'était
arrivé sur la loi Duflot si jamais vous
avez mal utilisé le procédure
parlementaire là le texte est réputé et
bien être totalement inconstitutionnel
pas sur le fond mais sur des raisons de
procédure auquel cas qui le texte
terminé soit vous avez une censure
partielle c'est à dire que c'est pas la
procédure sur le texte mais vous avez
quelques dispositions notamment pour ce
texte qu'on va appeler des cavaliers
sociaux par exemple l'index senior a
priori pas de conséquence financière sur
2023 je vois pas comment c'était pas un
cavalier social donc là vous avez des
dispositions précises qui sont censurées
qui disparaissent du texte ce que peut
faire le président face à cette
disparition c'est soit décider de
l'introduire dans un nouveau texte soit
il va y avoir de la pression là-dessus
vous avez aimé le 49 aminatoires le 44
aliné à 3 et le 47-1 vous avez peut-être
entendu bientôt de parler du 10 à Liné à
deux c'est à dire la seconde
délibération et là vous risquez d'avoir
une pression des oppositions pour dire
mais écoutez la réforme elle est pas
obligée de passer par 49 à 3 elle est en
partie censurée proposée au Parlement de
Red récupérer de revoter dessus et
auquel cas c'est possible après la
censure ou même d'ailleurs après
l'examen du Conseil consuel qui a eu
censuré ou pas auquel cas le Parlement
se reprenant sur le texte si Emmanuel
Macron fait ça il est assez probable que
les parlementaires votre compte c'est
une sortie de crise on rejoint ce qu'on
disait sur le CPE c'est une sortie de
crise assez dépend
retour du texte saison 2 la réforme des
retraites au Parlement oui quand on voit
comme c'est très fort à je dirais tendu
des choses bordélisées pour reprendre le
terme de Gérald dahmanon et puis pour
les Français le sujet est bien sûr
central la retraite et quand on regarde
la priorité des sujets qui les
préoccupent on trouve des sujets qui ne
sont pas la retraite la santé
l'éducation le grand âge avec pour ces
trois catégories des ministres qui
peinent à incarner que les Français
globalement ne connaissent absolument
pas et je le répète cette question de
l'inflation tu pourras l'achat du
travail qui paye mal donc oui ce retour
en arrière serait catastrophique pour le
gouvernement on l'a vu marquerait la fin
symbolique du quinquennat de son
ambition réformatrice et puis créerait
je pense une frustration contenue du
décalage entre ce sujet et d'autres
sujets plus prioritaires pour les
Français et certains proposent une
dissolution pour sortir de la crise
Frédéric vous avez posé la question aux
Français que voteriez-vous en cas de
législative prochaine c'est le
rassemblement national qui s'organion
oui alors ce n'est qu'un sondage une
hypothèse d'attention de votre
législative alors qu'il n'y a pas de
dissolution mais je n'ai pas peur de
dire que ce sondage est un véritable
tournant puisque pour la première fois
pour une élection législative pour la
première fois dans un sondage le
rassemblement national arriverait en
tête aux élections législatives depuis
la version du calendrier électoral
qu'est-ce qu'on voit à chaque élection
législative une perte en ligne très
forte de 30 à 50% entre le vote Le Pen
que ce soit le père ou la fille et le
score du fnrn vous allez châtives là 26%
c'est 7 points de plus
qu'aux élections qu'aux premier tour du
12 juin dernier c'est du jamais vu alors
égalité bien sûr avec la nupesse mais
qui progresse nettement moins que le RN
et ce qui frappe c'est la capacité du RN
d'être un vote attrape tout de capter
même 20 % de l'électorat AG et de
capitaliser et surperformer dans les
catégories les plus opposées à la
réforme des retraites les personnes
actives les 35 49 ans les 50-64 ans
celles qui vont être confrontés
directement à l'application de cette
réforme si elle est appliquée et bien
sûr le salariat la bataille du travail
qui avait gagné Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007
François Hollande en 2012 Emmanuel
Macron 2017 étant le train d'être gagné
donc rassemblement national alors oui
c'était la question qu'on se pose qui
tire profit de cette crise alors on
entendait des personnalités de la nups
encore hier soir Jean-Luc Mélenchon dire
c'est nous quand on voit cette enquête
c'est pas tout à fait évident c'est le
rassemblement national en tout cas il y
a un décalage très fort entre la Voice
la protestation la saturation de
l'espace médiatique par la nupes les
insoumis et Jean-Luc Mélenchon et des
gains entre guillemets électoraux qui
seraient relativement bas ce qui frappe
sur sondage au-delà de nu pas ses rênes
c'est le vote sanction qui serait
déployé au détriment de renaissance mais
ça veut dire qu'il le paye la stratégie
de la France insoumise
la France insoumise le paie dans les
ions de cette stratégie d'obstruction
cette stratégie de se faire entendre
alors quittons les sondages j'ai entendu
madame Rousseau dire que fondament se
trompait souvent elle a peut-être raison
quittons qu'est-ce qui s'est passé hier
dans cette législative partielle en
Ariège on va parler avec Benjamin Morel
tout à l'heure on voit la nupestre la
candidate nupes en recul par rapport à
l'élection de juin alors bien sûr avec
une candidate socialiste dissidente mais
le fait majeur c'est que dans une terre
inconnue faudra rassemblement national
le RN a raté le second tour d'appel de
points ça aussi que le RN un tel score
en Ariège je pense que c'était là une
première et je répète c'est pas un
sondage c'est du vote
évidemment je suis absolument d'accord
il faut bien comprendre que le lectorat
en règle générale lors du législative
encore plus d'une législative partielle
il a piscine il est pas là et le fait
que là il vienne c'est extrêmement
révélateur de sa capacité de
mobilisation on a dit oui certes une
député RN a été battue à l'hôtel et
malgré tout si vous prenez toutes les
partiels depuis le dernier
renouvellement l'électorat ARN est là et
le simple fait qu'il soit là est déjà
extrêmement entre guillemets étonnant et
extrêmement révélateur donc là en effet
il faut pas penser que et bien les
dernières élections législatives ont été
une sorte d'épiphanie pour le RN qui
aujourd'hui aurait disparu on a quelque
chose qui semble devenir structurel et
ça ça change tout en termes de d'effet
du mode de scrutin on avait songé à un
mode de scrutin qui depuis 1962
produisait des effets de vagues entre
droite et gauche avec un je dirais une
une prime au centre aujourd'hui c'est
plus le cas on a quelque chose qui
semble s'installer visiblement dans la
durée et qui va faire que on va y
revenir sans doute mais toute
dissolution apparaît extrêmement
extrêmement hasardeuse parce que là a
priori alors il faudrait voir ce que ça
donne en siège évidemment c'est toujours
très très hasardeux de le faire mais
c'est ça
mais a priori on aurait une plus de
députés RN et on n'aurait pas moins de
députés nul parce que les Circus pour
des raisons la Nupe c'est concentré dans
ses bastions et donc ce faisant on
aurait assez probablement un parlement
encore plus un gouvernable
qu'aujourd'hui et donc aujourd'hui
pourrait manuel Macron la dissolution
n'est non seulement plus une option mais
structurellement les centres
apparaissent représentés non plus une
majorité à eux seuls et une minorité par
les autres que comme les autres et ça
c'est assez nouveau dans la vie
politique oui alors on n'a pas fait de
projection en siège parce que on a pas
assez oui et puis pas de second tour
posé on n'est pas dans une campagne
législatives ce serait quand même
périlleux pour ne pas dire inapproprié
de faire une projection mais c'est clair
que qu’est-ce que ce sondage consacre
comme au mois de juin la tripartition du
champ politique les
républicains restent sur un strapontin
et sur un rôle d'appoint et c'est vrai
que avec la le rapport de force
précédent du mois de juin on a eu nous
avons une assemblée entre guillemets un
gouvernable avec cette majorité relative
dont on voit les effets pervers contenus
du fonctionnement démocratique du pays
avec un tel rapport de force c'est vrai
qu'on peut envisager un RN avec 50 60
députés de plus n'oublions pas que le RN
n'a pas gagné une vingtaine de sièges à
1 à 3 points quand on passe de 19
c'était son score aux élections
législatives à 26 ça veut dire quand
même que ces sièges se régalés mais en
tout cas ce qu'on peut ce dont peut-être
sur c'est peut-être qu'on redescence
sera le serait Renaissance Modène
horizon serait le premier groupe de
l'Assemblée nationale mais avec une
majorité encore plus relative que
maintenant et une assemblée encore plus
difficile à maîtriser pas de majorité
absolue même en cas de dissolution bien
sûr vous êtes prudent qu'est-ce quid
d'une campagne électorale quid des
dynamiques quid des seconds tours
d'événements de campagne que bien sûr on
mesure pas à froid mais avec un rapport
de force pareil encore plus serré en
terme de tripartition entre ces trois
forces ça paraît très hautement
improbable ça veut dire que l'exécutif
n'aurait aucun intérêt à la dissolution
n'a aucun intérêt à la dissolution et
qu'elle que les menaces actuelles de
dissolution vis-à-vis de ces
parlementaires sont probablement non
seulement du bluff mais peuvent être
contre-productives parce qu'aujourd'hui
on voit les tensions s'accumuler au sein
de la majorité on voit que horizon
n'aime guerre Renaissance qui n'aime
guère horizon et le modem que modem
n'était que le modem ce n'est pas non
plus tout à fait en délicatesse avec ces
deux autres membres que chacun rejette
les PPL de l'autre et que lorsque une
première ministre décide de faire de
d'essayer de sauver sa peau lors d'une
motion de censure personne n'est là pour
l'encourager dans les bancs vous voyez à
peu près l'état de la majorité
c'est-à-dire que si demain vous voulez
gouverner l'important c'est pas d'abord
d'aller chercher des whylène l'important
c'est d'avoir un interruple qui marche
aujourd'hui ne marche plus d'où tout le
travail qui est fait par Elisabeth borne
vis-à-vis de sa majorité parce que ce
que dit ce sondage c'est qu'il y a pas
de majorité alternative que vous pouvez
toujours vous amuser à menacer vos
députés de dissolution que vous pouvez
toujours expliquer que et bien si ça
continue on va retourner aux urdes et
que d'autres feront bien mieux le
travail la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui
et bien probablement la situation serait
pire pour l'exécutif donc il va falloir
faire avec cette absence de majorité qui
aujourd'hui caractérise le Parlement de
actuel pour terminer pour revenir à ce
qu'on se disait au début est-ce que
c'est uniquement le texte sur la réforme
des retraites qui jouent ou est-ce que
c'est aussi le climat social est-ce que
les violences dans la rue jouent sur les
intentions de votre notamment pour
l'électorat Agen alors l'enquête a été
faite avant la journée de mobilisation
de mercredi elle a eu lieu de lundi soir
à mardi soir donc ça prend pas en compte
c'est vrai que quand on voit la
décélération plutôt la baisse très forte
entre le total majorité présidentielle
vous avez son législatifs qui sont très
récentes et ce 22% clairement on voit
les ferments d'un vote d'un vote
sanction d'une élection intermédiaire
classique ou le parti au pouvoir se voit
sanctionner municipal 2014 pour la
gauche régional 2010 pour la majorité de
Nicolas Sarkozy bon c'est tout un climat
et je le répète cette personnalité cette
personnalisation du mécontentement
autour de la figure d'Emmanuel Macron
sans doute ce climat inflammable alors
j'utilisais aussi tout à l'heure qui
peut avoir des effets entre guillemets
bénéfiques le terme n'est pas très
heureux pour Emmanuel Macron mais pour
l'instant oui la majorité paye le
mécontentement sur la forme des
retraites merci on continue à parler des
violences étales à la une de la presse
régionale ce matin
[Musique]
et Alex elle a eu de la Charente Libre
les violences à Sainte solide
au chaos puisque le rassemblement de
Sainte-Soline ce weekend dans les deux
sèves contre des projets de méga bassine
à tourner à l'explosion de violence
selon les organisateurs 200 manifestants
étaient blessés l'un d'entre eux voit
actuellement son pronostic vital engagé
une trentaine de gendarmes ont été
également blessés dont deux qui se
trouvent en urgence absolue et encore
une nouvelle mairie a été visée par un
attentat c'est à la Une de Corse-Matin
la mairie de la commune d'apieto a été
particulièrement détruite par le feu
dimanche un attentat a signé par un
groupe indépendantiste Corse et qui
intervient trois jours après celui après
perpétré contre la mairie d'Afa Alex les
pénuries d'essence commence à toucher
les stations services des grèves et des
blocages des raffineries et des dépôts
pétroliers de plus en plus de stations
services connaissent des ruptures
d'approvisionnement cette allée une de
Presse Océan et du Progrès de Lyon
vendredi dans le Rhône par exemple 4%
des stations étaient en rupture totale
et 13% en rupture partielle et alors que
[Rires]
[Musique]
et bien de la hausse de la mortalité
infantile dans notre pays la France Neco
25ème rang européen dans ce domaine il
est donc préconisé de rassembler les
structures avec des plus grands
maternités mieux équipées ce qui est
inquiète les établissements en milieu
rural par exemple en
Occitanie la moitié des maternités
devraient la disparaître et on finit par
une note gourmande Oriane à la Une à
lire dans Ouest-France dans l'édition de
la Sarthe puisque c'est le printemps de
la rillette ce week-end au Mans et un
record du monde a été battu le record du
monde de la plus grande marmite de
rillettes au monde 1072 kg ça fait 4000
pots et donc ça fait quelques sandwichs
voilà
merci beaucoup Alex merci pour ce record
et si machin et merci fré
déric
[Musique]